okay
um my architectures for the kihon waza
they are very particular I'm going to
make a compilation of of seminar footage
it's something that a Seri Sensei showed
me um when he asked me to note this um
we were at a summer camp for the western
region so chiba's organization there's
probably like 4 or 600 people on the mat
and he asked me to uh film the class for
him he was the videographer for the
western region uh he was Ill on this day
and he said Davey do it for me but I
want you to pay attention to something I
want you to note how no one is doing
what cha sensei's
teaching and uh I didn't believe him cuz
I was a ferite right people had Rank and
they had title and they were popular and
and I they train with cha Sensei so
you would think they know what they're
doing and they're trying to do what he's
doing
um but here we had the top
ranking uh teacher in sheba's
organization telling me no one is doing
what cha Sensei is doing and so I filmed
the
class and as I was panning back and
forth I was doing what he asked to me
and he was right uh no one was doing
what Chiva Sensei was doing and that is
the case over and over that is not the
case here at R Dojo I'm very particular
your foot goes there your foot goes like
this and your hand goes like this and
the Hand shakee goes like this you can't
just with the forms where you have
a million different personality variants
of EO not that doesn't work okay there
is a uh rule to sound body mechanics so
you have to stand like that you can't
stand like someone else you have to move
like that you can't move your own way
okay everyone has to stand everyone has
to move the same way the whole uh uh
fetish of the individual in the modern
secular nation state is not part of iido
uh there's a way to be and there's a way
to stand there's a way to move so to do
the
architecture uh a EO have to do it that
way you can't do it any old way you
can't have a different variant of it for
every single dish you have on the
map
um in the same way that there's sound
body mechanics there's also sound
Kinesiology and then you have your
Tactical principles all these govern
that it's this way and not any way okay
uh it's very similar like when I teach
handgun
shooting um I had a I had a a recent
Academy
class and there was one female
deputy and she just was holding the gun
different how I taught her how to hold
the gun and I would come by every time
and I this is how you hold the gun I fix
her hands and I come by she's holding it
her way again and this is how you hold
the gun and it fixed her hands and I
came back and I go hey uh you do not
shoot better than me if you want to
shoot better than me you have to at
least hold the gun like I'm holding the
gun it's not something weird it's the
industry standard hold the gun like I'm
telling you to hold the gun over time
she did do that and at the end she
touted all her expertise in firearm
training to that one moment okay uh so
there's no not any way there's a way
that's the way you do it so when we look
at your
EO it violates a lot of the rules of
anatomical positioning so anatomical
positioning is a pre-application a
pre-calculated application of force on
areas of UK's body with the expectation
that it's going to have X effect X
effect being desired okay so when you're
doing your e
um you're staying in
[Music]
place and he's going around
you and then you're coming around this
way and then back this way I'll do it
one more time the cam will move whatever
they
want your feet stay in
place you move
him around you
you move him back towards
you then into the
technique
okay it doesn't change if we go a little
quicker nothing
changes
okay um I just want to look at that one
part so let's look at the anatomical
positioning that we want to achieve with
the initial test ofak okay what we want
is him to enter into the front inward
kazushi
pattern here that's what we want to
generate and eventually we want to be
able to stand in here for the EO
technique for the
adashi okay so I have to move in a way
that gets him if he's in katate stay
there please
to have his other foot come
forward and to have his body Teeter into
this
shape
okay so my anatomical positioning should
not do anything that is not conducive
towards that end
okay
so when I make him go around like
this the other foot
foot
is not ever going to become so
heavy that this foot becomes light you
just you would just make him walk
exactly like he is do you see then we're
here so we're
here now if
I take whatever tension is here and I
move it back this way eventually the
shoulder turns back towards me when I
needed this shoulder to be over here and
I needed him to be like this so if you
watch your video slowly on slow motion
you'll see that your UK always turn back
towards you and then go like
that
okay so let's look
at how we don't have him turn back
towards me and how we get him in that
your to position okay so first let's
deal with the second one cuz it's the
easiest he comes
around all
right if
you in any
way pull on this
shoulder then he's going to turn toward
you so if you pull on this arm in any
way eventually he turns towards you
so we don't the the the arm is going to
tell you how much you can manipulated at
the
grip to where you don't bring this
shoulder back
okay that UK is going to tell you that
in their body so I'll leave your
footwork for
now okay so if I'm
here and I can move
without making that shoulder really open
to this point you
see there's a little back but not he's
not turning towards me it's not until I
start to bring it back
here so be cognizant you can't do
whatever you want with this
arm and you can't be wherever you want
with this arm because even as I do this
it's still opening up a little towards
me but if you go way past that then he's
going to turn towards
you so cogniz is that how much tension
is in the arm is telling me how much I
can manipulate the wrist grab to the
ceiling of don't let this shoulder turn
towards you now if you add the footwork
uh move this way I starting to change
the relationship of where we where I was
before
okay if I add some weight onto that leg
you see I add some weight onto that leg
and then I add what I just mentioned
this arm is telling you how much you can
move it out towards you away from the
shoulder before you start turning the
shoulder
okay if I move my body then I don't have
to move that shoulder at
all so I move out instead he goes by me
I keep the bend on his elbow so that I
don't extend the grip away from his body
I keep it keep that elbow bent and that
shoulder will not turn back towards
me just looking at that opening hand
work
[Music]
I'll exaggerate the arm
pull brings in to me pull too much on
the
wrist too much on the
wrist okay uh bring that into what
you're doing be cognizant if for any
reason
I saw in
eel that
shoulder start to
turn TR start to open up I'll do
it he's going I saw this you see it
opened up on me you got to go to
something else you don't keep forcing EO
the technique's been up
okay um
so just looking at the shoulder I I
can't get the adashi angle with that
shoulder coming back towards me and
that's kind of setting you up for
failure look to your footwork and then
bring some Awareness on how far your
hand can go towards you which means how
far their hand can go away from them
because it will open up the shoulder too
okay um
[Music]
go way out here I start to turn
this on samuk you have so much tension
tense your arm please that if I move it
at all I'm starting to turn that
shoulder so she locks up her tension you
can't turn it but it makes it much
easier to keep it
bent okay so leave it bent when that
happens okay you decides what you do
with your arm how big your spiral is
okay
[Music]
for
for for